muchas gracias me encanta verlo
virtualmente siempre es un privilegio
hablar en la conferencia de seguridad de
múnich
y como dije en este momento como dije
hace un año yo dije que el kobe 19 s era
un gran peligro enemigo público número
uno y recuerdo que en ese momento
la gente estaba un poco preocupada
algunos me siguieron dijeron te droz
cuando dicen que es muy peligroso el
enemigo público número uno
dicen no está exagerando
desafortunadamente en el último año
todos
[Música]
entendimos unas lecciones bastante
dolorosas hemos visto
qué tan peligroso es este virus aunque
kobe 19 aunque la pandemia del coi 19 es
una crisis global de salud
no todos los países han respondido de la
misma manera y no todos los países han
sido afectados de la misma manera muchos
países han tenido éxito al prevenir o
controlar los brotes generales ha habido
pruebas rastreo de contactos cuarentenas
distanciamiento físico y temas de
higiene más caras así como todos ustedes
conocen en combinación con estas medidas
comprobadas las vacunas nos están dando
una esperanza real para controlar esta
pandemia pero entender el poder completo
de estas vacunas requiere tres cosas
primero debemos necesitamos gobiernos
que patrocinen completamente a kovak
cosas y que le donen a ellos ahora nos
agrade agradecemos mucho los anuncios de
varios países del g7
en segundo segundo ya que kóvacs compra
vacunas que tienen el sello de
emergencia de la oms necesitamos que los
manufacturados compartan las dosis
completas y que cumplan con todas las
regulaciones en tercer lugar
necesitamos individuos que levanten su
voz
que defiendan la equidad de las vacunas
en las vacunas cuando la gente habla con
una sola voz los gobiernos escuchen la
equidad en vacunas no es solamente lo
correcto también es lo inteligente
mientras tome más tiempo suprimir el
virus habrá más oportunidades
de cambiar cosas que hacían de las
vacunas menos efectivas podríamos
terminar en donde empezamos se están
desarrollando más vacunas se están
aprobando se están produciendo ahora
suficientes para todos pero por ahora
las vacunas son un recurso limitado
debemos usarlas de manera efectiva y
como es tan efectiva como sea posible
para volver a su pregunta que si estamos
teniendo éxito sí
los casos y las muertes están en declive
hay una herramienta hay una caja de
herramientas de medidas por los que se
ha comprobado tenemos una cantidad de
conocimiento cualquier hemos nadie nos
puede soñar hace un año pero tenemos
asegura de usar estas herramientas
exitosamente esto significa usarlas en
todos los países para proteger a los
grupos que están más en riesgo esa es la
mejor manera de salvar vidas y restaurar
la confianza del club
reiniciar la economía global estamos
haciendo progreso
nos haremos una pregunta de una líder de
un líder george walker de los eeuu para
usted señor el director general no es
secreto que el lado ms se ha convertido
en un tema político doméstico acá mi
pregunta es mirando es el futuro cómo
podemos asegurarnos de que el mundo
específicamente la alianza
transatlántica esté mejor alineada para
enfrentar ese tipo de desafíos de nuevo
muchas gracias yo sé que cree usted
doctor de dios
sí muchas gracias es una pregunta muy
importante como ustedes sabemos
importante
aquí lo más importante para luchar
contra pandemias como estas es creer en
la solidaridad
en solidaridad por supuesto inicia desde
la unidad nacional eso significa que a
nivel nacional
cualquiera con creencias distintas
sean ideológicas sean religiosas sean
otras diferencias debería trabajar
unidos para luchar contra un enemigo
como este como una pandemia como esta si
ustedes recuerdan lo primero que
estábamos pidiendo al inicio de la
pandemia era unidad nacional
por cierto tuve la oportunidad de hablar
con ambos lados del pasillo no solamente
en eeuu sino en otros países una cosa
que les dijimos les pedimos por favor no
tengan diferencias políticas no se puede
ustedes pueden usar otras cosas para
avanzar en esas para seguir compitiendo
basados en su ideología política pero
por favor no hagan que este virus sea
político este virus debería unirlos y yo
sé que algunos países han escuchado e
incluso tienen un comité de conjunto
de partidos políticos para planear
juntos para ejecutar su plan juntos la
unidad nacional es central como usted
dijo y eso se convierte en la base
también en la solidaridad global sin
solidaridad 10 global disponibles este
virus no puede ser vencido
es un enemigo común
y se disemina cuando no cooperamos
y cuando miramos hacia nosotros en vez
de mirar hacia afuera e intentar ayudar
el mundo en el que estamos viviendo es
una comunidad global ahora es una
pequeña aldea y la única opción que
tenemos
o globalmente en el mundo que está cada
vez más entrelazado e interconectado más
cercano que actúa como una villa pequeña
la única opción es la cooperación y la
solidaridad eso es lo que debemos
empezar por supuesto a partir de ahí en
esa relación basados en el atlántico o
sea en otras partes del mundo el mundo
debe entender que la salud ahora es
central cuando falla la salud cuando una
pandemia como éstas aparecen cuando nos
convertimos en huéspedes de un virus se
puede ver su impacto y es económico
el impacto político también menciona el
ustedes afecta todo
y todo el mundo es rehén de un pequeño
virus eso muestra que la salud es
central y lo que hemos estado
defendiendo en estos descubrimientos en
salud para todos
debe ser tomado en serio o sea con el g7
con el g20 que 3777 todo el mundo
debe tomarlo en serio por supuesto
cuando decimos que la salud debe asumir
un rol central
es un tema muy importante es la
inversión en salud pública cuando empezó
la pandemia muchos países incluyendo
los países ricos fueron sorprendidos
porque todo esto pasó sin inversiones
salud pública no habían invertido en
cuidado primario
y el virus tomó ventaja porque no había
una salud pública que los defendiera en
muchos países han invertido en
especialidades de medicina pero ayuda a
eso a combatir un virus como este no la
parte más importante del sistema de
salud que lucha la pandemia en la salud
pública el cuidado primario
y ese fue un fracaso incluso en las
economías más avanzadas de nuestro mundo
entonces la inversión en salud pública
bueno quiero hacer un énfasis en esto es
muy importante y luego habría una cuarta
pero bueno creo que es muy importante
ver a la salud en relación con los otros
como una sola salud